let's go next to steph from wisconsin
steph you were on the air
hey david uh thanks for calling on me
my pleasure
i have a question um
what are your thoughts on the new travel
restrictions in terms of people now
needing a test 24 hours in advance
well as before i believe it was
72 hours yeah i just
i heard about this because a friend of
mine sent me a message while we were
filming the show about it um he travels
regularly and and you know i i do too
and i've had uh i guess it's
three trips since the start of the
pandemic for which i've needed
return tests to come back to the united
states i think it's very very
problematic from a logistical standpoint
now i don't know whether it will prevent
disease from spreading it may or it may
not i really don't know
from a logistical standpoint it's
actually very difficult right now
to get well first of all if you're
looking at a pcr test which is the most
accurate i don't know of any place where
you can get it guaranteed within 24
hours maybe there's some places but
especially in other parts of the world
it's very very tough which means that
you're going to be overwhelmingly
relying on antigen tests now the
anti-antigen test i don't know if you
heard my story from when i was in spain
in august but on the way back my
girlfriend had two false positive
antigen tests we ultimately went and got
a pcr but you know it took six hours to
find it and then another 24 to get the
result if we had been
with within 24 hours of the flight we
would have simply been stuck in spain
because of the less reliable antigen
tests so i i just logistically i don't
know how this is going to be managed and
when i read that i was thinking it looks
like i'm traveling domestically for the
foreseeable future
okay yep that that was exactly what i
was wondering in terms of the rapid
tests over the more reliable ones so
that answered it exactly thank you yeah
and you know in some airports like i
remember when i was flying through
frankfurt
you could get antigen tests and there
would be different prices for different
time uh like time windows but it was all
the same test so if it's like if you had
24 hours
then it was like 80 bucks and if you
needed it within six hours for a flight
it was 150 and if you needed it within
one hour you could pay like 350 dollars
but it was all the same test and of
course the risk would be if you get a
false positive you're kind of screwed
either way you know
yeah yeah exactly
all right steph thank you for the call
very good question
all right there goes stuff very good
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend
when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video